Twitter right now is suing the US
government they have filed a lawsuit in
federal court uh claiming that the US
government uh well they're fighting them
on the right to publish their full
transparency of reports and I think this
is kind of interesting because with all
this NSA stuff that we're hearing about
we know that the NSA go can go into your
Skype account and see your chats or
whatever it is or the video calls or all
the Facebook stuff and Gmail etc etc
Twitter is the most transparent because
you're tweeting publicly so the only
really hidden thing in Twitter I guess
is the DM so I do think that's kind of
interesting but we've got a quote from
the Twitter
representative we filed a lawsuit in
federal court seeking to publish our
full transparency report and asking the
Court to declare these restrictions on
our ability to speak about government
surveillance as unconstitutional under
the First Amendment the ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals is already considering
the constitutionality of the
non-disclosure provisions of the NSL law
later this week so this is interesting
as I said Twitter does seem to be more
trans trans arent why is the most
transparent social media company the one
that's fighting the US government
Kim I I think it's great that they're
fighting for transparency because you
know we we've seen this blowback on a a
lot of different social media and also
email and different web platforms of you
know hey we have to tell you this is
happening but that's all we can say and
I think you know it's it's only fair
that they should be able to have some
control over happens in their own
business yeah is there any chance that
they win this lawsuit I mean the NSA is
just going to do what right the even if
they win like they're going to do it
anyway right or that that they okay you
congratulations you won and now we're
going to figure out some backd door
Channel together to take the information
yeah well I I think it's unlikely at
this point that they're going to win
which is why it's so unsurprising that
they're publicizing the fact that
they're fighting them if you know that
you're not going to be be able to beat
the US government why not at least get
the sort of authenticity and credibility
that comes from being seen to be trying
to fight them I mean it's it's like sort
of a I don't know a silver lining I
suppose to the issue have you guys kind
of given up on the online privacy thing
you know there was a point maybe six
months ago where especially around here
and and in most circles on the left at
least where we were talking about this
constantly right just constantly talking
about and now I feel that people have
just kind of resigned themselves uh
sadly uh obviously you have't personally
the look you're giving me but really
that that the basic the sort of broader
Community I like the side eye that the
broader Community is just kind of giv up
and been like yeah you know what they're
just going to do it and there's nothing
we can do well it's easy to feel
powerless because you almost literally
are powerless but I think you have to
continue to fight back and show that
you're not going willingly and you have
to struggle and you have to you know
send messages and call your Congress
person and you need to be United en
forces like with the eff you you can't
just like lie down and give up
especially if it's you know your privacy
that that's yours that's that's that's
sacred to you yeah and of course you
know we're having all this stuff with
net neutrality and that's looking like
it's going to disappear and uh it seems
to me we had the Golden Age of the
internet we had it and now we're
shifting it was really good it was free
it was free and it was and we got music
and it was and it was there and it was
honest and now we're we're going into
something else what should we call this
evil phase that we're going into I step
two I guess I don't know and it's scary
I just saw you know internationally a
lot of uh International isps are looking
to see how the us is going to rule in
net neutrality I I think it's
interesting that in a country like
America that's known for being
politically apathetic at at the best of
times we've had a couple of big moments
where we had like the the protest
against the war with Iraq originally we
had Occupy Wall Street we had the the
fights over privacy in the wake of the
the Snowden Revelations but then like
you can only galvanized people for so
long and out of Occupy Wall Street we
got a little bit but not much but at
least we are still talking about
equality and out of the fights over
privacy we got a little bit in Congress
but not much but at least people are
thinking about it to some extent but you
they did get upset when they found out
the NSA was spying on them they weren't
up until Diane Feinstein they found out
she you know they were reading her
emails then yeah yeah yeah well as soon
as John Boehner was involved in the
fening I knew that he'd take it a little
bit more seriously um but you can only
keep people galvanized for so long um a
year is is pretty long to keep activists
working another reason I think Twitter
is kind of the the Lynch pin of this
whole thing is to me it seems that
everything going on in the world all the
revolutions that we see all of the stuff
going on in in Ferguson and in Hong Kong
and what happened in Egypt it was all
fueled by Twitter that was the one it
wasn't Facebook I never if something if
there's some breaking news I never go to
Facebook I I I wouldn't even think of
going to Facebook but you do go to
Twitter so is Twitter sort of like the
last Bastion of this like we really need
Twitter to somehow remain independent
right Twitter can be a beautiful thing I
mean we're able to hear about things
that we wouldn't know about like we
learned about Ferguson so much after uh
you know so much like locking down not
speaking but like people were able to
talk and be public and be open and that
was beautiful that's one of the best
parts of the web and social media yeah
and I think as it becomes more
ubiquitous people are going to or
officials are going to want to tighten
that down a little bit Yeah I think that
Twitter is still probably the Premier
Service internationally for for that
sort of I guess crowdsourcing of protest
but we can't forget that while Twitter
remains you know on top in America
internationally there are Regional and
Country specific equivalents that might
be taking over some of that
responsibility right are you have you
guys signed up for L yet that's what the
kids are all they're all on the L are
you on the L you're not on the L I'm in
line for L you're maybe I I know a guy
I'll see what I can do for you um all
right final thought on this what do you
fear more giant companies or giant
government it's a bit of a jump from
where we started but I think it's
interesting where are we at now is it
the companies that we should fear or is
it the government I I don't know the
answer I used to always say that it was
the government that I fear giant
government or do you fear the equally
sure yeah I think is is somewhat simple
in that uh we we benefit from in America
the corporations have bought the
government so why not just fear them and
you get both there you go all right we
fear everybody around
[Music]
here